it will be left-hander ryan yarbrough
making his seventh traditional start
11th overall appearance the record two
and three the era 427 in 52 and
two-thirds innings of work
mccutcheon is out of there to start this
game
and a cut in the midst and boy that
pitch that changeup just completely
disappeared away from segura reece was
five for 13 and he had two
huge home runs in the series against the
marlins
they had the pitch
a bouncer morphed to me
bouncer
from philadelphia it looked like it
bounced in front of the plane but it's a
base hit that's a seven game hitting
streak
jt riyamudo
liner into right that ball will stay out
margot out there to make the catch
he's been outstanding this year he's
making his 11th start he's got one
complete game an era of 2.38
[Applause]
did he go
he did
adrian johnson says he went around
and the pitch to lao
on the outside corner called strike
three jaundi diaz sitting 253.
that's going to be a beach hit past the
diving miller
quinn near the line in right
and diaz takes it the other way the rays
have a base runner so now we have austin
meadows the d.h
that's a shot toward right center that
has some carry and that's gonna go
home run for austin
on a one-on-one pitch
meadows stays hot and lines it out of
here
[Music]
and austin meadows
we talked about it in the open he puts
the ball in play 77 of the time it's
gonna be in the air that gives you the
opportunity for extra base hits and that
one was good for four
and a quarter strike three got him with
a slider he struck out the side
wave and a mess
chasing that one
let's punch toward the right side one
hop loud gets over there and a nice pick
at first by joy lou goes and gets it get
it open up need a little help there's
g-man
one-two
he got him a cut the mess to retire the
side
o2 pitch swinging a foul tip
five strikeouts for wheeler
swag and a miss
six strikeouts for each pitcher so far
in this ball game
two outs here in the third yeah take the
spinners on that that's a beautiful look
wow and now the o2 pitch
yeah we're gonna miss he got him struck
out the side seven k's
oh ryan gorby
looked like he flinched a little bit
there was a little hesitation from jt
first walk he does
pitches upstairs throw to second base
hits jt and scoots out to shallow left
fields
well the rays knew something we didn't
know
wants to jump to jail i mean that's
first move you got no chance of getting
jt you end up rushing the throw you
throw a sinker to second base e2 been
there done it
swayed ahead of this
brad miller is out of there out on
strikes for the second time man left and
third
o2 pitch coming
got him threw him a change up he's had a
couple good changeups today eight
strikeouts for wheelworth with two outs
here in the fourth
two now
and a cut in the miss
and i'm out in front swinging over that
breaking ball now both these pitchers
with eight strikeouts and
getting them in different ways
and he bounced beautiful bun up the
third base line no play at all what is
diaz doing i was watching the other
monitor he was way way back way back
behind the bag first and second one out
now te reyes
two balls two strikes
and he lines it out toward right field
that's a fair ball going down in the
corner one run is in roman is flying to
third he's being waved home to reyes is
at second roman fell going from third to
home and he's hurt
he crosses the plate the phillies lead
it or phillies have tied it at two
and terres is over at third base
here's this uh swing by thereas
right here watch as he comes around he's
slipping
the fact that he got up and still made
it home
sean picassi joe girardi lift him uh
carry him off the field well a
disappointing turn of events for ryan
yarbrough here four to third three hits
two runs plus a man at third he walked
two struck out eight made 78 pitches
and
with the top of the order and a man at
third the infield comes up with ryan
thompson on the hill
and down to third nice pick up there by
diaz no to first gonna be in time
and it's swinging in a bench and that
ladies and gentlemen was off the plane
get it in there
he does ties him up swinging to miss
nine strikeouts for wheeler wendell
doesn't go this time and a strike three
called on the outside corner 10
strikeouts for wheeler for the third
consecutive game it's the 12th time in
his career
wendell does not go
pitches a call strike three 11
strikeouts for zach wheeler
ready to go and now the 2-2 pitch
and a breaking ball on the inside corner
a called strike three that matches his
career high in strikeouts
it's a dozen
[Music]
got him
96. it's a career-high 13 strikeouts for
zach wheeler
k's in his last two starts
there he goes and that's ball four
and he ate upstairs so we get
back-to-back walks here
after the two strikeouts to begin the
inning
and there's a live drive base hit out
the bat of joy diaz is going to head to
the plate there will be no play and the
rays lead it three to two
jim and joy on the first pitch drives in
the go-ahead run
ground ball softly left side gobbled up
by boehm good play
finishes it up 5-3 on the put out a run
does score on the rbi single by choi
matt joyce the hitter joyce up for the
first time matt is over his last 28.
and a high fly ball to deep right field
fair foul it's a fair ball home run
matt joyce ends an o for 28 by tying the
ball game up at three
and he does it against a left-hander
and against his former squad if you're
gonna break out that's the way to do it
tom
that was towering
swag gonna miss he got him 14 strikeouts
for zach wheeler
it's the second highest total in major
league baseball in a game of this year
segora punches it through the hole on
the right side a leadoff single here in
the eighth inning okay
hoskins lines it into center field a
grab
by kermeyer out there he came on and
found himself in a position where he was
gonna have to leap to make that catch
and did
3-1 on the ground hit the mound up the
middle
cigarette's throw it's oh it's going to
be a time a rosarito called out at first
oh gosh yes i mean he's almost past the
bag by the time that ball goes into the
glove the rays are going to have a
runner at first
oh this one
bouncing in and away and now rosarina's
gonna go all the way to third
and a little tapper that's going to be
no play at the plate no play anywhere
and the rays take the lead 4-3 rosarena
comes home with the go ahead run on an
infield base hit
and the raised lead four to three
oh and that pitch hits joy
and ball four that's gonna force home
iran
it's 5-3
and a swing and a miss he went upstairs
to get him and strikes him out
to end this ball game and the rays win
it
it's a 5-3 final